we are talking about
semiconductors today yeah
yeah yeah and um
i finished our exam 2 concept map that i
thought
maybe you guys would find useful this is
much like
the last time when i gave you guys the
concept map i'm just giving it a little
earlier this time
and here you can see all the connections
right between the um uh the lectures the
recitations
the problem sets okay um the quizzes
and uh the quizzes over here the goodie
bags and the exam
topics and speaking of the quizzes
tomorrow there's a quiz and so you could
look up here and say okay well what's
going to be on that quiz
right might cover some molecular orbital
theory might cover
uh the bandgap stuff that we did on
monday and that you covered in
recitation yesterday
oh and your uh intermolecular forces we
also do
and you're asked to bring to the quiz um
uh the voltmeter
and these uh these large leds okay
now i'll talk about that a little bit
more about this in
in in a in a few minutes okay so
remember to bring that
laura will also send a reminder email
about that
okay you have voltmeters you have
vote meters how many of you have ever
had use of how many of you this is the
first time you're using a volt meter
okay how many of you haven't used one
but you've never seen one
you've used it before but you've never
had one this accurate
as the 309 one right yeah
oh you never know when you need a volt
meter you should
always carry it with you with the
periodic table
now on monday this is what we had
i'm gonna this was a conduction band
this was a valence band and then we had
a conduction band and a valence band
that were a little bit closer together
and then we had this case where
maybe it's uh it's it's filled up
somewhere
in the middle of a band and remember the
valence band is filled with electrons
and the conduction band is not
right in in the simplest picture
and this this this this difference in
energy between
this vbn right that's the vbm the
maximum
level of the valence band and the cbm
the minimum level of the conduction band
that energy difference is the gap of the
sum
of the material right
here you can see energy gap
equals zero well in this case it's a
metal
or if you want it's a conductor and
we'll talk about
why it's a conductor uh more on friday
but a little bit today why metals are
conductors today i really want to focus
on this case
all right so that's a metal when there's
no
gap in the material if the gap is large
then that is an insulator insulator
right oh what do i mean by large well
what i mean is it's not
in the range of this special case which
would be
say zero less than the gap
less than around 3.5 electron volts
this is the case that i want to talk
about today
i want to spend today talking about
semiconductors those are those are
called semiconductors
let's write that here semi
conductors uh sometimes
semiconductors sometimes you'll see them
called metalloids
other you know sometimes you'll see them
called insulators
with small gaps they're all kind of
right
and and the reason but so metalloid
thank you
okay now the reason why we classified
these and why this
range of gap is so important is what i
want to convey to you today
these are really special materials these
semiconductors
okay now before i do that
i i want to i want to just clarify one
thing
okay and i'm going to use diamond and
graphite as an exam
as as an example on monday
what we did is we we talked about the
concept of
bands with a very simple 1d model
right this was a 1d model
of s orbitals 1s orbitals
i said well if i have a mole of 1s
orbitals then that goes
into a band and i called it a 1s band
right i would say well if you fill it in
different ways
that is what determines the properties
but i want to be clear and i stress this
on monday i want to stress it again
all right whether this forms this
and then the next that you know whether
you get like a 1s that forms a band like
this and then a 2s that forms a band
like this
and then another one you know maybe 2p
like this
or whether there's breaks in them or
maybe these
kind of overlap so you get like overlap
and you get sort of something like that
right all that depends
on more than just those atomic orbitals
it depends on more it depends on how
these things are bonded
this is such a great example i've got
the same
element here it's carbon
there's nothing else in this system
carbon pure carbon everywhere is carbon
but on the one hand i've arranged it in
a certain way
and on the other hand i've arranged it
in another way and their properties
couldn't be more different
right and and so so like you know just
to take this a little further
right if i if i think about
diamond on the left diamond is an
insulator diamond has a gap of five and
a half electron volts
five and a half electron volts it's an
insulator right
now is it but okay that makes me think
of methane remember methane you have
these
sp3 states sp3 sp3
sp3 okay and the reason it formed sp3
is because all these h1 1s
states came along right h h
h these are one s's
one s right and so carbon came along and
it said well if i
arrange if i got four of you here
like this and i arrange
myself if i arrange my orbitals in such
a way that then i can arrange the atoms
so that they're
minimizing repulsions that gives me
methane that gives me the ground state
of methane but the only way to do that
is to have
four equivalent orbitals those are
hybrid orbitals
we talk about this when we talk about
hybridization
the idea being that if i took one of
these and one of those
right so now you can imagine how it's
going to look you know all this now
right there's a there's a 1s orbital of
hydrogen
you know that those will form a sigma
and a sigma star and occupy that bonding
orbital
that's the idea of methane that's the
idea of molecular
orbital theory with some hybridization
right and it's going to form those bonds
along each direction but now i'm talking
about something different
i'm not talking about such a simple case
i'm talking about
one mole of
sp3 that's what diamond is
look again the carbon atoms have done
the same thing
they've said hey wait a second okay
that's not four hydrogens it's like 10
to the 23rd
carbons all in one small space
how can we organize to lower our energy
and so they form well we know this that
it's going to form a band
but it doesn't just form a band
and then half fill it that's not what
diamond does
no actually diamond breaks this apart
so that you have a huge
gap and those are filled and that then
those are not
so this is not and the sp3 band
in diamond breaks apart
into a valence and a conduction band the
valence band is full
the conduction band is empty why well
you don't need to learn
the specifics of how to get from there
to there but i wanted to show you how
complicated this is
i won't ask you whether the sp3 band
splits
or not i just wanted to show you how
dependent this is because now
look you can understand this now right
so i got four electrons per atom going
here there's a huge gap
and then nothing in there that's diamond
5.5
ev gap one mole of sp3
in diamond now it depends on the
structure
if i had just put them together in some
amorphous soup with no
oh amorphous that's a word that's coming
later
but if i just put them together with no
order i wouldn't get this
this splitting if you take graphene
which is one of those sheets and makes
stacks and you got graphite
it's another form of pure carbon in that
case
you've got your sp2 bonds to form in the
plane
and those also split and they fill but
now you've got
your pi bonds right and those don't
split
so in graphing right so in diamond so in
graphite
what you get is you've got your sp2s
right you got a mole of those and you
got your your peel your p
electron remember those right now you do
a mole of that
and you got the same thing but see now
you got these are the sp2 bands sp2
bands
it also split and remember i've got my
electrons here my sp2 electrons and
those there
but now i've got the pi bands
that didn't split graphene graphite is a
metal
you can understand it by by looking at
the bands of these materials
now again let me emphasize i am not
going to ask you to know
when something splits like this or not
why didn't the pie band split into two
like these did
when do two when does an s and a p
become a single band
versus an s band separated by a p band
i'm not going to ask you to know that
but i wanted you to see it
it doesn't just depend on the initial
states it depends on the structure
right of those atoms depends on how
those atoms are bonded together
good okay now
what about this semiconductor what about
this semiconductor
well if we take a semiconductor
and we look at it i told you this on
monday there are two things
that you can do right in your goody bag
especially one is you can take an
electron
and you can shine light on it and
it's going to excite this electron up
just like in the bohr atom right you can
absorb photons
if the photon energy is the energy
between
one state and another we did a lot of
this earlier but see
in a semiconductor remember
i've got an almost infinite number of
states here
and so and so what i need is for that
photon
there's not an exact value here there's
a continuum
ah but here it's forbidden just like in
the bohr atom there's no states there's
no electron
right so here the energy the photon
the energy of the photon
absorbed let's write this out absorbed
has to be greater than the energy of the
gap
right this is the energy
of the gap this is the energy of the gap
now by the same token i can take the
same semiconductor
and run it the other way i can put a
current on
it and feed electrons electrons
from current
so i can attach it to a battery
and there you go this is a semiconductor
where i'm literally all i'm doing is i'm
feeding electrons into its conduction
band
and but now when those electrons fall
down
into the valence band they emit
a photon photon
emitted
and just so i have room
with energy of the photon emitted
is going to be exactly equal to the
energy of the gap
you can see that because these electrons
i might i might inject them into the
conduction band anywhere but they're
going to wind up
very very very quickly going to this
minimum conduction band state and that
gets me to another important point which
is on the absorption
side i can overshoot this like i said i
can i can absorb higher than the gap
i can't absorb lower but i can absorb
higher
and if i do if i absorb higher than the
gap
right so let's say this is my state then
that electron
so if my photon comes in and it kicks an
electron up really high it's a high
energy photon
then that electron very quickly will go
back down
and that's called thermalization
so what happens is that electron
electron loses energy
loses energy to heat
to get to the cbm
okay we'll come back to this later
that's thermalization so the electron
can be kicked up
by light to any level but it's going to
very very quickly go to the cbm that's
why when i inject it
that's why these are the same color you
know these are
these are high quality leds clearly
oh they work that's a good thing um and
you know so the batteries might be
slightly different
yeah and the currents might be different
a little bit i might be injecting
electrons at different
parts of these conduction bands but this
is always green and this is always red
and that's because those electrons very
quickly
get down to the cbm and the vbm and the
cbm and the vvm are determined
by the semiconductor inside by the
semiconductor
inside okay
well you've also got you know so this is
a photon emitter
right here i've made a light emitter
right but i've also got a detector which
is what i said on monday
so now i take an led and
i hold it and it goes in tight this is
what's inside of the emitter it's the
same thing it's a semiconductor
but these two semiconductors have
different band gaps
that's why the light is different they
have different band gaps
now i've got one with some band gap and
i hook it up to my voltmeter and
and i just look is there a current or
not
right if the if this thing conducts
through it it means that electrons have
been promoted
from here to here and that's something
we're going to talk about today
electrons cannot move around easily if
they're in the valence band but once
they're in that conduction band they're
free
how do i get them there well you've got
power
shine red light on it does it conduct
check the volt meter
right i'm literally holding two
semiconductors and doing these two
processes
right here in in each hand it's a power
that i have i have semiconductor making
light semiconductor
absorbing light or maybe not if i shine
red on this and i get no current
well it means that the energy of the
photon from a red
you know from a red light source is too
low it's maybe it's
able to excite it up to here but not up
to here given whatever the gap in
here is you see that right so the
semiconductor
has this powerful maybe i take a
different semiconductor
and red excites it or maybe it doesn't
so i go to a higher energy photon
right you are with this goody bag you're
touching and feeling
semi-conductor physics and chemistry
and chemistry because band gaps
and materials are rare you see
if you look at the periodic table and
you classify it by metals
metals and non-metals right so
insulators conductors and then these
weird things in between
there aren't that many of them there
aren't that many of them
but as you can see these are really
really important
technological materials right why
because you can this is visible light
the semiconductor
range here is in the range of light we
care about
visible uv so i've got an electronic
material
where the electrons in it can be can
interact
with currents small currents even
and wavelengths of light that are things
we can see
you can imagine how important this could
be for example for making leds
but i need a lot more flexibility in in
in my material set and that's where
chemistry comes in so this is
one why this matters for today so look
you know i mentioned that
getting red was hard back in the day for
color tv
because the red phosphors were difficult
to make for leds it was blue
and in fact there was a lot of work
around gallium nitride here's gallium
nitride in one structure
oh notice this there's gallium nitride
it's not on here
darn it gallium nitride and other
structures have different gaps
oh there it is there's one okay but the
point was they wanted blue
they wanted blue and they needed to make
a material that was both cheap to make
and lasted so it didn't like degrade
and gave you blue light and that was
really hard and that's what the nobel
prize was given for
in 2014 because without blue you can't
make white light
right so there's all sorts of
technologies you simply can't go into
with leds until you get blue how did it
happen it happened
because of chemistry because people
figured out how to change the
how to take one element and another
element and then maybe alloy them
together maybe you take gallium nitride
and you alloy a little bit of aluminum
in here and now all of a sudden
that means mixing in right now all of a
sudden you've got a different
band gap okay band gap engineering
is really the centerpiece of the
semiconductor revolution
now the conductivity we've been talking
about connectivity
and we'll talk about metals on friday
okay here we are
insulator is really low at least
conducting
10 to the minus 25th hook your voltmeter
up to
teflon 10 to the minus wood
right low conducting materials but but
we're interested in these and look these
are kind of in between they're not very
good conductors
that's why they're called semiconductors
right yeah
but the fact of the matter goes back to
what i've been saying
and this is the next point i want to
talk about which is
i cannot i cannot
have so in a semiconductor
there's no electrons
if there's no electrons in the
conduction band
then there's no electron
conduction
now i've said this before i said this on
monday i said it already that why not
on monday is it well the electrons are
stuck what does that mean
they're stuck stuck in the bonds stuck
in the antibonds
they're stuck in states now the point is
here
that here you've got these this valence
band is filled
now if i want an electron to move
through a material
right which is what conductivity is
after all
by the way siemens conductance one of
our ohms okay
if i want electrons to to move into
material they
need freedom they need freedom
right what does that mean well it means
that i
i'm trying to move through this wire and
and for an electron freedom means i can
go to any state that's nearby
state a wave function a state of
probability
that i can move to and then to that one
and then over here and then oh there's
there's something there i don't want to
be and i got to go this way
that's a bad thing over there it's
scattering me
i'll go this way but if electrons don't
have the ability to move
into a free state they're not going to
conduct
that's why you got to get the electron
up here
why because the the conduction band i
shouldn't really fill this in
i'm just showing you empty states there
the conduction band has 10 to the 24th
states
freedom freedom
so as soon as an electron gets up there
it's like oh i go anywhere i want i can
be there
i can be there i can move in response to
this field
that i'm that's pushing at me right
i can conduct i can't do that unless i
have conduction
unless i get electrons into the
conduction man this is okay
now this is why you can see right there
metals are clearly good conductors
based on our band picture because those
electrons near that
you know that line there you fill them
up and they're halfway in a band
but right up above their almost
infinitesimally small energy away
is an empty state and another empty
state so
that's why those these ones you can see
it's going to be hard
i'm going to have to shine really high
energy light to even get
or or really high temperatures again
semiconductors are special because their
gaps are right in that range
where i can get electrons to go from the
valence band to the conduction band
in different ways and there's two
different ways that i want to talk about
okay now the first way is simply with
heat and this is why i mentioned this on
monday
actually no matter what there's some
probability for an electron to have a
high enough thermal energy
yeah electrons get hot too right
everybody
feels the heat and so it but so that
thermal energy
can be enough to get the electron to
knock it up above
to knock it up above so with thermal
energy
you can get um let's see
at room temperature
for silicon so this is the case of
silicon
which has a 1.1 electron volt gap
silicon 1.1 electron volt band gap
this is a really important semiconductor
and for silicon
at room temperature i got about 10
to the 10th
electrons in the conduction band
okay per centimeter cubed of material
this is how we think about it
we think about how many of these do i
have per volume
right it's a good way to measure it
these are also
an electron in
a conduction band also is called a
carrier
so you say for silicon at room
temperature
i will have just because i can't help it
because there's that many
are getting i'll have about 10 to the
10th elect carriers carriers
in in the conduction now what the
carrier
is a carrier of electricity that's why
it's called the carrier
right it carries electricity so those
are the ones that are carriers the ones
that made it up
now but if i go to 600 so now i'm going
to go
to 600 kelvin oh we only use kelvin
kelvin is the thermodynamic energy scale
temperature scale
10 to the 15th carriers
per centimeter cubed
this seems like a big number but is it a
big number
what's a big number we know and like in
this class
the mole so like roughly ish
is this a big number per centimeter
cubed or not
it's actually very small right but i
i need them to be there if i want
better conductivity if i want conduction
in these semiconductors i got to put
electrons
up in the veil up in the conduction band
remember that i i just as as a important
point
i mentioned the energy of room
temperature the thermal energy of room
temperature kbt
is about 0.025 electron volts so that
seems way smaller than 1.1 ev
it is but that's because that's not what
temperature really looks like
temperature is a distribution
is a distribution now you don't need to
know that for the band gaps we're going
to come back to distributions
boltzmann distributions when we talk
about reactions reaction kinetics
later but that's why
at room temperature the tails right
hot means a range of energies hotter
means
a wider range of energies and it's those
tails
that have enough energy to get over the
gap and into the conduction band
okay it's those tails that's why i got a
little bit
of electrons that get up there at room
temperature
now if you look at a plot this is
here's a great way there's the log
conductivity of silicon it's from april
and there's the log connectivity on this
side of tungsten that's a metal
totally different behavior
how is that possible well we're going to
explain the metal on friday
today we're interested in this i'm
this one now we understand thermal
energy
excites carriers into the place where
they can be free and conduct
right so as i increase the temperature
hotter and hotter there's the
temperature in kelvin right i just gave
you examples from down here
and now we're going higher and higher i
get conductivity up orders of magnitude
higher for silicon
you know why now i'm populating i'm
getting
over this gap and i'm populating the
conduction band
so the answer is we just need to run our
semiconductor industry
and our phones and our lights at around
a thousand kelvin
right no problem all our devices no
that's obviously not a good idea
how do we get around this the answer oh
such a good word it's chemistry
chemistry gets us chemistry saves us
as always you've got
to know your chemistry
and in particular this is not the doping
that you may read about
in the news related to olympic athletes
this is
this is the introduction
this is the introduction of some
small amount
small amount of an impurity and impurity
is something that
wasn't there normally it's like
something i mixed in
that's not normally there but if i put a
small amount of something in it
then i can tune the properties and in
this case i'm talking about
i'm talking about the connectivity
okay so how does this work
if i look at this case so i'll do one
case here
all right i've got my silicon atoms
arranged in this solid
that gave me a band gap and again
that is due to the arrangement of them
if i didn't arrange them in this
particular way i might not have that bad
gap
i might not have the same band
structures
right it depends but this is what i get
for the
silicon arrangement when the bang gap is
1.1 ev
which is the one we use in most of our
electronics
right but the thing is i want so this
would be
silicon this is just silicon
by itself valence band and
here's the conduction band cb
vb now i want to add electrons
into this material and so you can just
kind of imagine how this would work
right
if i look at if i just look at a lewis
dot diagram for silicon let's just
forget about the structure for a second
okay
silicon has these four valence electrons
so you can imagine
you know silicon might look something
like this
right and okay i'm going along and i'm
going along
it's tetrahedral and stuff but now i'm
going to take one out
i'm going to take this out and i'm going
to make it phosphorus well that
what what is phosphorus it's wait where
did it go huh panic and then
i'm recreating what happens for you guys
i found it
ah oh that was close
but yep phosphorus is right there it's
right next to silicon
it's group 15 instead of 14. it's got
one but it just has one extra electron
right so maybe it could do the same
thing
but then have this one extra
electron that's doping
where does it go because it's all about
freedom it looks down it says wait a
second
there's no states here i can go to no
states
i can't go anywhere here so i will have
a state because i have picked phosphorus
carefully
and because of the way the chemistry and
the bonding works with phosphorus in
silicon
this will introduce a state
near the conduction band and that's the
key
so now we've got the valence band
and we've got the conduction band
and what's happened is there's a new
level here
that is called the donor level
that level is where the
extra extra
p electron goes
it can't go in here remember this is all
filled right
so now i've doped with dope
with p and
oh but look if i've got an electron here
now this difference in energy is really
small
it's really small i've engineered it
this way i've thought about this so
if i put phosphorus in here that extra
electron isn't sitting far away anymore
from the conduction band in fact now
it's so close that room temperature just
kicks it right on up so effectively
it's going to go up here because that's
a small
delta e between the donor level and the
conduction band this is how doping works
this is how doping works right so i put
a phosphorous atom in
there's an extra electron that comes out
of that the extra electron needs a state
it gets a state that's called the donor
state donor makes sense right because
it's
donating an electron
into the conduction band right
once i get the electron into the
conduction band i'm home free
because now i've done what temperature
was doing before
but i did it with chemistry right and
and so you could ask questions like this
right
how much phosphorus do you need to
substitutionally dope substitution meant
just what you substitution was i took a
silicon atom and i substituted it
that's substitutional doping to
substitutionally dope a mole of silicon
and get a free electron density of 5
times 10 to the 17th i'm going big here
because look temperature and gazoon type
temperature
okay maybe i'm willing to run my
semiconductor in a really hot room
my phone at 600 kelvin i'm still only at
10 to the 15.
i want 10 to the 17th now how much
phosphorus do i need
well you can solve that problem
i'll just write down a couple of the
steps right so the
volume of one mole
of silicon is
uh one mole right times 28.1
grams per mole oh and i got the density
on there too
right divided by 2.33
grams per centimeter cubed how did i get
the density
i looked it up in the periodic table
right
and so one mole of silicon is going to
give me 12
centimeters cubed of
silicon one mole of silicon is 12
centimeters cubed
but each i need 5 times 10 to the 17th
electrons in the conduction band right
per centimeter cubed that's they see why
per centimeter cube is a good measure
here
so that means i need 12 times that total
right
so i need 12 times that so i need 5
times 10 to the 17th p atoms
why p why do i need that many p atoms
times 12
right it's 5 times 10 to let me just
write my units here to be very careful p
atoms
per centimeter cubed times 12
centimeters cubed that's how many p
atoms i need
in this mole of silicon to get
what but it's one to one because each p
atom had one extra electron those other
electrons are in the bonds
they're not going into the conduction
band
it had one for one one electron went to
this donor state went into the
conduction band per phosphorus atom so
if i want that many carriers
if i want that many free electrons i
need that many atoms
well you guys can look up the phosphorus
grams per mole and you can get that this
is 0.0003
grams of phosphorus that's really not
much
you see why it's called an impurity
right you see why it's called an
impurity
that's not much i i have all this
silicon
and i only need 0.0003 grams of
phosphorus
and i've bumped up the number of
carriers
by orders of magnitude
not only that i've done something really
important as well
and you can see this because now if i
plot something like
you know temperature versus
number of carriers
well you know you saw the graph for
temperature before right it was
it was it was like this
that's the graph from a couple slides
ago
but now if i do it with chemistry
it's flat i can choose at any i can
until the temperature gets really hot
right
i could give myself more room here
because that's
kind of the point right number carriers
i can make this now
flat
from doping
from temperature and and so you can see
okay at a certain point
at a certain point yeah you know the the
the temperature goes up up up and a
certain point
the temperature is going to be so hot
that i'm adding electrons even beyond
this right but you saw what temperatures
are a thousand degrees kelvin
no this allows me to have a predictable
flat number of carriers in the
conduction band no matter the
temperature
just think about how important that is
this is why semiconductors were kind of
discovered in the 1800s
but it wasn't until physicists and
chemists
were able to control the band gap and
how to put carriers in and out of it
until they could really work on the
semiconductor revolution which is what
led to
snapchat did i get snapchat still used
yeah i knew that slack
okay now you can do the same thing going
the other way
you can do the same thing going the
other way because if i've now put
if i now put gallium so if i dope
with gallium well you see gallium
has
one too few electrons
and so if i dope with gallium
what i have so the gallium is there you
see
where is it it's on the other side
where's silicon
okay silicon right phosphorus is
over there group 15. silicon is group
14. gallium is group 13.
one fewer electrons but it really wants
to make those four bonds
the material isn't happy if you break
one right and so what does it do it
it steals an electron it takes it
it says i need an electron to be happy
so it takes one out and that's called an
acceptor level
acceptor
level where what's happened is the
gallium has
actually pulled an electron out of there
and that leaves behind a positive charge
this is called a hole
that's called a hole a hole is and think
about it
if i take an electron off of an atom
it's positively charged
if i take an electron out of the vbm
there's a positive charge
in there that's really important because
these positive charges effectively
are like electrons they're like negative
charges but they're positive
so they also can conduct
they also can conduct right
and that's really important so these are
these are two different
types and you can imagine the brilliance
of the naming
these are p-type because it's a positive
charge
and these are n-type because it's a
negative charge
those are n-type semiconductors what
does that mean i've used a little
chemistry
sprinkled a little something with extra
electrons it's got negative charge in
the conduction band
p-type p means positive
it means that i have introduced states
here because i needed an electron and
say i need an x-ray i'm going to grab it
from somebody i don't care who
and so you create a positive charge in
the valence band that can conduct
electricity just like a negative charge
in the conduction band can
this is what the entire semiconductor
revolution
has been based on and really so much of
the focus was on simply taking these
elements in particular silicon and
germanium
but then many many more as i showed you
in the led graph
many many more have been used
to make to engineer
these simple what are seemingly simple
properties right the band gap
and the doping and so i'm not going to
go through this in detail i'm just
leaving it here so you have it but you
get charts like this
right so like here you have okay carbon
is up there and what can you do well if
you dope it with boron
you can see that it's p-type you see
that because i've got one
fewer electron than carbon so i'm going
to grab that from the valence band
create a positive charge p-type
right i could also dope silicon and
germanium
and i'd say silic carbon silicon
germanium so i'm looking in this middle
column
doping it with either side that's it why
can't
i put you know why can't i put
aluminum in carbon why didn't they list
that well because there if i try to put
an aluminum inside the carbon network
the network gets all messed up
doesn't fit so that's also important
right
can it fit but it's through this
that the semiconductor revolution
started it's only through this
this kind of control and this knowledge
of atomic orbitals really
if you think about it right and the
structure of the atom
now i'm not going to talk about
transistors but this did lead to
um the development of the transistor if
i take there's a night really nice video
there it's like eight nine minutes i
suggest you wait until your friday night
uh social um but you know if i take a
p-type
and i take an n-type and i take a p-type
and i put them together
some really important things happen
so important that it led to this which
is the very first transistor
that's the transistor it's it's a dope
semiconductor
one type next to a dope semiconductor
another type
now those are the three uh people
bardeen shockley and
bertain who who won the nobel prize for
this work
and that's the first transistor does
anybody know how many transistors we
make today
per second that's the that's the only
time metric we can use yeah it's
something around
10 trillion we make 10 trillion
transistors
per second today this is a big deal this
started at all and it's all about
chemistry and then the physics of this
device
right this led to diodes and photodiodes
this led to the whole revolution
and what i want to point out here is and
you know that this also
led it called on chemistry so i love
this chart this is actually
unfortunately they didn't update it but
this is intel's
an intel chart that they used to show
and what they're showing is how are they
making chips
right how much of the periodic table do
they need
to make the current chip well in the 80s
there's almost nothing
lit up here there's a little bit over
here that you can't see
stuff we just talked about but look at
the 90s and look at the 2000s and today
it's 75 of this
it's literally 75 percent of this is in
your phone
now why the reason is exactly what we've
talked about today
because they need more and more and more
flexibility and ways
to tune the band gap and the
semi-conducting properties
of these materials and the doping why do
they need new waves because they're
making them so darn small
you know they're so small it gets harder
to figure out how to do it right how to
do it in a way that's also stable over
time for example
right so they need new chemistry this is
a call to action
to the field of chemistry and chemistry
responded
right and there's there's the the data
on the cost i thought that was kind of
cool
okay so you know these are orders of
magnitude of of uh
a cost and and number of transistors um
and i'll i'll say one more one more why
this matters
um because the semiconductor is also the
same thing we use
uh to to take electricity from the sun
to generate electricity
from the sun and you can imagine this is
what i you know
you are doing that in your goody bag
right you're you're literally using this
semiconductor
right to generate electricity okay by
shining light on it
right why is this important well i like
this comparison right all the coal oil
gas
known to humans is what you get from the
sun in about 20 days
um this is the sun now we've seen the
sun before
this is how we see it in our class the
sun
is is a spectrum of different
wavelengths and intensities
and this is already on planet earth
right because you can see
those chemistries that are in the
atmosphere have already absorbed
right remember ozone down here helping
us with uv radiation and out here you
got a lot of water and other things co2
those are absorbing that's why it
doesn't look smooth
yeah but the point is i you know i want
a semiconductor to absorb as much of
this as possible if i want a good solar
cell
right i should absorb as much of this as
possible
um and but the problem is that it's a
constrained optimization problem
so let's let's see if i uh i'll just use
this
if i have a you know i'm now
this goes back to bore by the way
remember
bore absorbing light it's just now i've
got an actual solid i don't have an atom
right i've got a solid which is what you
need if you want to generate a current i
got to hook leads up to it
right so but my solid is a semiconductor
and you can imagine say well if my gap
were really really tiny then
any amount hey almost any amount of
this spectrum would uh would excite
electrons
right and and i might grab
most of that spectrum i might absorb
most of it but the problem with that is
that then
all of these will thermalize like i said
in the beginning
loss to heat
loss to heat so if my band gap is really
small i absorb a lot of the light
but i lose most of it as heat but if my
band gap is really big
then there's so much of this light that
i cannot absorb
so i want a big but by the way also the
voltage that you get out of your solar
cell
is essentially this band gap so if i get
to really really small band gaps i have
almost no voltage
that's bad too right but if my band gap
is too big
oh i'll get a high voltage no you won't
absorb any photons
so it's a constrained problem it's a
constrained problem and you can actually
solve this
and you can plot in fact here's a little
animation
oh energy comes in from the sun it
excites an electron this is how
powerpoint sees it
leaves behind a hole and you get them
out that's the solar cell
okay and this is the chart i want to
show you
because you see if if i take this
constraint into account that i don't
absorb light if the gap is too big but i
do absorb light and it all goes to heat
if the gap is too small
it means there's some sweet spot there's
some sweet spot
and that's what is plotted here this is
the band gap of a semiconductor
and this is the maximum that that solar
cell efficiency could be
that's the maximum that it could be for
that gap so you can see the sweet spot
is right there
is right there that's a thermodynamic
derivation called shock liqueur of the
maximum
efficiency you could ever get out of a
single material and notice if you put
the materials here silicon is 90
of the solar cells you buy today and and
notice that it's not
quite at its maximum potential it's also
not quite
in the middle where you'd want it should
have a slightly higher gap
you get to higher efficiency right but
these materials out of gallium arsenide
they do have the right what is gs that's
not an element
gallium arsenide it does have a a better
gap
but it's it's much more expensive right
and so we go
and a lot of solar cell research is on
getting as close to this point as you
can
see you guys on friday
you